les gilets jaunes sont donc de retour je
sais pas dire qu'ils sont rentrés de
vacances et il appelle à la mobilisation
ce week end jérôme rodriguez qui est
l'une des figures du mouvement appelé
ainsi cette semaine sur son compte
twitter à rendre visite au président
macron au palais de l'élysée puisque ce
week-end ce sont aussi les journées du
patrimoine qui sont l'occasion d'ouvrir
un certain nombre de bâtiments de la
république est ce que il faut croire
dans un une renaissance du mouvement
c'est en tout cas c'est pas la vie
d'elizabeth bornes la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire alors
d'aller dire c'est normal elle est au
gouvernement
mais surtout elle considère qu' on a
déjà fait le job écoutez je pense que le
message des français il a été reçu cinq
sur cinq ans président de la république
par le gouvernement je rappelle qu'on a
gelé la hausse de la fiscalité qui a eu
des mesures sur le pouvoir d'achat
et puis il ya aussi la convention
citoyenne qui va démarrer début octobre
donc le temps c'est aujourd'hui à
construire des solutions et on est
vraiment à l'écouté des français pour
trouver le bon chemin
sauf que les français ils sont assez
partagés 1 sur ce sur ce sujet des gilet
jaune
regardez ce sondage récent sondage
réalisé par bva
on a posé la question aux français
souhaitez vous que le mouvement des
gilets jaunes se poursuivre dans les
prochaines semaines
alors certes il ya une petite majorité
qui répondront mais il ya encore quand
même une grosse tiers des français qui
soutient le mouvement et 11% qui ne se
prononcent pas nicolas de mac vous êtes
surpris par cette ce soutien populaire
qui quand même n'a pas disparu malgré
les 17 milliards d'euros
malgré le grand débat et malgré les
violences oui mais ce mouvement tournant
rond point que maintenant on se fie
nord-est s'est beaucoup affaibli il n'a
plus de projection vers l'avenir alors
qu'il en a eu à ses débuts et puis il
s'est perdu pour un certain nombre de
raisons sur lequel on pourra revenir
mais c'est vrai que l'opinion avait un
soutien par procuration au fond n'était
pas satisfait de ce pouvoir qui a quand
même fait mouvement
du coup on n'est plus dans les sommets
quand même à il y avait des soutiens à
60 70 % au moment quasiment maintenant
voilà je n'ose aller jusque là parce que
bon mais 37% donc on en est loin mais je
sakho ya une générosité aussi des
français pour tous qui manifestent quand
même c'est une tradition de se montrer
en solidarité mais ils se sont ils se
sont pourtant grandement grandement
isolé je ne crois absolument pas à une
reprise massive alors il peut y avoir
encore des manifestations fortes voire
violente qui se produiront mais il n'ya
plus de quand il n'ya plus de deux
revendications résonance avec la société
je trouve maintenant c'est un mouvement
qui s'est marginalisée radicaliser dans
ses formes d'expression et qui ne
correspond plus un écho dans la société
française se croit pas du tout à la
petite de marianne d'ailleurs je me
semble ça me semble du grand comment
dire de la grande poésie voilà c'est
très bien on va passer tout de suite la
parole à etel girard vous devenez la une
de marianne on rappelle ségara lincendie
nicolas domenach la regarder avec
intérêt puisque il a eu quelques
responsabilités dans ce journal pourquoi
est ce que vous vous croyez un incendie
sociale on croit alors nuance on croit à
la 110 social pas forcément à une
reprise stricto sensu du mouvement des
gilet jaune d'une ampleur numéraire
extraordinaire nous on pense que
effectivement le mouvement des gilets
jaunes a perdu dans son intensité a
perdu en dynamique n'a pas de leader
mais les causes restant les mêmes c'est
à dire les fractures françaises la
france d'en bas requis ce sans oublier
une unsa une politique qui donne
l'impression
de ne pas écouter ce que la france des
ronds-points a pu dire l'année passée
donc on pense que oui l' incendie
les causes de l'incendié restent en
présente lincendie n'est pas à exclure
mais ça pourrait être une dans une
coagulation beaucoup plus composites que
celle qu'on a vue l'année passée une
coagulation qui pourra mêler une partie
d'anciens gilet jaune des syndicalistes
le mouvement le mouvement syndical des
militants pour le climat donc quelque
chose de boue finalement beaucoup plus
large dans une intensité de
manifestation qui sera peut-être par
l'intensité violente qu'on a pu voir
l'année passée mais qui en tout cas à
l'égard du président de la république
montre une défiance tout aussi
importante
à l'appui de ce que vous dites écoutez
cette réaction de citoyens payeurs l'un
de nos internautes qui est en train de
réagir en direct sur twitter et qui nous
dit le mouvement gilet jaune est devenu
omniprésent dans l'esprit de tout
contestataire de la politique
gouvernementale et compris par exemple
pour la réforme des retraites et
citoyens payeurs nous dit c'est une
sorte de franchise en fait effectivement
et puis voici deux autres internautes
qui semble proche de ce mouvement
l'olivier qui nous dit le peuple crève
de faim ne ressentez-vous point son
angoisse ainsi que ses inquiétudes du
lendemain et tonton le grand débat a été
un moyen de s'accaparer des
revendications pour ne pas y répondre
oui
le mouvement va redémarrer matile de
broc f votre point de vue le mouvement
va-t-il redémarrer et puis la question
qui me brûle les lèvres votre tenue
vaut-elle soutien à ce mouvement le
mouvement va demeurer démarré je ne sais
pas ce que je pense c'est que on a des
gilet jaune dans la rue encore et que
s'il ya une vraie raison à ça les
raisons et les causes profondes on était
peut-être en partie traités par quelques
mesures qui ont été proposées il ya des
baisses d'impôts qui sont prévues
c'était une demande ça veut dire légère
allègements pour pour la population mais
mais je pense que ce désir profond de
pouvoir vivre en fait juste décemment de
son salaire de pouvoir prendre des
décisions pour son environnement local
etc
c'est des causes qui sont beaucoup plus
profondes et auquel aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ne répond pas puisque nous
n'avons absolument pas de d2
vrai mouvement de décentralisation du
pouvoir de décentralisation fiscale qui
pourtant redonnerait du pouvoir aux
citoyens et leur permettrait de pouvoir
prendre des décisions directement au
niveau local donc je pense que
redémarrer je crois pas pas avec
l'ampleur qu'on a eu l'année dernière je
rejoins je rejoins etienne là dessus je
crois pas mais par contre je crois qu'il
ya vraiment des fractures très profonde
et je vous rejoins là dessus ça faisait
peut-être mais il ya de vraies fractures
profond qu'on qui n'ont pas été
réellement traités et la centralisation
et de la fracture entre paris et les
télés lé territoire l énorme aujourd'hui
la liant à plusieurs reprises la saison
dernière si on peut dire sur ce plateau
vous avez pointé du doigt la difficulté
de ce pouvoir à comprendre le peuple
c'était d'ailleurs l'une des causes du
mouvement des gilet jaune est ce que
vous faites toujours le même constat ou
est ce que ça a changé pendant les
vacances avec les annonces en a plus
qu'a dit les gilets jaunes ont été une
bonne leçon pour moi donc c'est une
raison de plus pour les villes et jaune
pour continuer moi j'aurais pas dit ça
mais enfin bon c'est son problème
non je pense que réunir chaque semaine
pendant quelques temps encore dix à
vingt mille personnes dans toute la
france pas c'est pas un exploit ya
forcément des gens qui sont habitués à
ça donc c'est devenu la sortie du
week-end le seul problème effectivement
c'est comme les mains il est marqué sur
l'antenne là leur slogan pour appeler à
la mobilisation contre le système qu'est
ce que ça veut dire contre le système
sap à sanaa pas lequel system système
métrique
le système est donc il ya un moment
donné où effectivement ils sont en
manque de réelle de rennes
revendications même si le problème des
retraites peut être un slogan pour
l'épauler gilet jaune
deuxièmement la désertification des
campagnes peut l'être aussi
et ça c'est un réel problème et ils
peuvent s'intéresser au climat ce qui
serait quand même bizarre parce que les
premières manifestations étaient contre
la hausse du prix de l'essence ou bien
la limitation de vitesse et aujourd'hui
ils seraient pour y seraient pour la
en accord avec les défenseurs de
l'écologie et de la hausse de l'essence
par exemple pour limiter les effets de
l'essence et du gasoil
il ya un certain nombre de
contradictions mais non moi je vois le
mouvement s'éterniser au sens strict du
terme mais dans des dents des dans des
temps des demies nuance beaucoup plus
faible qu'il a été jusqu'à présent même
si jusqu'à présent on s'est trompé on
s'est beaucoup de se sont trompés tout
au long de l'année dernière et c'est
tous trompé en disant ces flacons match
promet d'être d'être humble cette année
treize ans je vais vous donner la parole
nicolas domenach mais d'abord je la
passe à nos internautes qui réagissent
en direct
babineau nous dit c'est comme si ce
mouvement était éteint mais pas mort et
c'est ce qui provoque la fébrilité du
gouvernement
nicole qu'elle croit que le mouvement
pourrait reprendre plus fortement selon
ce que notre gouvernement va inventer
peut-être sur la réforme des retraites
et puis un dernier point de vue en tout
cas cet instant celui de breny tôt à mon
avis le mouvement c'est trop essoufflé
pour vraiment avoir du poids mais
peut-être qu'il pourrait y avoir une
évolution de la forme de contestation
je vais vous passez la parole comme
promis nicolas domenach mais je voudrais
d'abord si vous voulez bien qu'on écoute
le président de la république parce que
dans un constat assez lucide
lui-même reconnaît que le les raisons du
mécontentement de la colère voire de la
peur des gilets jaunes n'ont pas disparu
c'est en français dans le texte parce
que c'est une femme entretien à nos
confrères américains de time inc
mais de transition économique digital
technology climate and is you don't
improve sa dette ou de life in win crise
the level of au fur et colas de mac vous
ressentez chercher nos concitoyens le
niveau de peur augmente
je crois que le niveau peur augmente ce
qui me fera plaisir dans dans le
discours du président de la république
c'est presque le moindre sinon le
renoncement l'optimisme qui était quand
même sa marque de fabrique
je suis très étonné quand même de cette
marche arrière présidentielle parce qu'
il était dans l'optimisme jusqu'ici que
c'était important pour ce pays d'avoir
donné le sentiment qu'on pouvait sortir
de la crise l'affronter et se rassembler
là il est beaucoup plus prudent il nous
fait le coup de feu de l'immigration des
choses comme ça qu'est-ce qui nous
remettent en arrière quoi il est il est
sur une défensive qui lui ressemble se
trouve qu'il ne lui ressemble guère
ce qui est positif en revanche est au
fond qui l'en rabah de son arrogance
qu'il a coûté beaucoup je crois mais qui
est la spécialité de tous les présidents
qui arrivent au pouvoir mais simplement
comme la situation est plus plus
délicate on est sur des charbons ardents
cette société plus en douleur donc
c'était encore plus insupportable qu'il
balance ses petites phrases qui mettait
d incendie généralisé à chaque fois donc
il semble avoir compris on voit que dans
la dans la gestuelle dans les mots il
est plus prudent
regardez par exemple cette citation à
laquelle faisait allusion daniel
bilalian à l'instant c'est toujours dans
l'interview au times quand il dit d'une
certaine façon les gilets jaunes ont été
très bon pour moi parce que cela m'a
rappelé comment je devais être mais ça
me rappelle une citation une étude dont
j'ai souvent parlé ici qui était une
étude américaine qui dit qu'il n'ya plus
au monde que deux types de personnes les
sommaires et les any where au début
emmanuel macron c'est un annuaire c'est
à dire il est international il travaille
dans un open space dans n'importe quel
aéroport il a un ami hong kong à
singapour et au et nous moi j'en fais
partie nous sommes les sommes mais on
n'est pas contre
progrès mais on est de quelque part on a
envie d'appartenir à un pays
quelque chose qui nous rassure qui
montrent que nous sommes des habitants
de quelques pas et pas any where